MEP s discuss a 20-18 budget in line  with EU priorities and new challenges  there are plans to put more money into  tackling youth unemployment major  earthquakes have devastated parts of  Italy Parliament votes on mobilizing  funds to help Italian regions recover  the Commission updates Parliament on the  recent scandal over contaminated eggs  due to the illegal use of a toxic  insecticide commissioner France  timmermans and an EPA takes stock of  judicial independence in Poland the EU  has threatened legal action if the rule  of law is not protected occupational  cancer is the leading cause of  work-related deaths MEP s are voting on  better protecting workers from  carcinogen exposure at work